hold up so mufasa dies right but what
happens to his body
hyenas don't usually eat lions and
there's no other animal that eats them
except other lions so watch this scene
one more time is that you don't think
wtf so that means
tick tock did it check talk already did
it
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that
just can't wait for you to smash that
subscribe button to help us get over the
10 million subscriber mark
you know disney's original lion king is
one of the greatest animated movies ever
made heck it is probably one of the
greatest movies ever made
period animated or otherwise and one of
the reasons it's so great is that the
story it tells is extremely simple and
straightforward there's a kingdom
there's a good king a son in line to
succeed him an uncle who'd like to
succeed him a murder plot
a lot of guilt and a lot of growing up
to restore balance it's tragic but
triumphant epic but
intimate and there's not a whole lot
else no stupid b plots no extraneous
characters no awkwardly shoehorned in
merchandising opportunities or universe
building cameos there's just no fat on
this one which leaves pretty little room
to theorize since by the end
the bones are picked clean but speaking
of bones recently a new theory is
cropped up on the internet tick tock
specifically
suspecting that the lion king might be
holding a dark secret in plain sight and
no it's not the leaves in the wind
spelling out some secret message
wait what do they say pause the video
matt
pat is king wow who knew that a 1994
disney classic would have so much
respect for me no friends today
online theorists are asking the question
that no one ever thought they needed an
answer for
what happened to mufasa's body after he
died
namely did scar eat his dead brother
ladies and gentlemen bear those teeth
and ambitions because it's morty time
leave your theories in the comments
below
i'll pick my favorites in the next
episode of morty
i am so glad that we're trying to make
this a thing now okay so here's the
breakdown
in january of this year the tick tockers
classy king zero and not
alexis lol presented an incredibly
compelling theory that really got the
internet's brains
working here's what they noticed in the
movie mufasa dies by falling from a
cliff during a wildebeest stampede simba
discovers his father's dead body
not realizing that evil uncle scar was
the one that caused the entire situation
scar convinces him that he'll be blamed
for the quote-unquote accident and that
he should flee
then sends his three main hyena henchmen
to chase him down which they fail to do
because
no one is good at their freaking jobs
not even in the animal kingdom
come back editors come back i didn't
mean you you guys are great you guys are
great the last time we see mufasa's
physical body
scar is standing next to it while simba
and the hyenas run away
scar returns to tell the rest of pride
rock that mufasa and simba are both dead
which apparently they accept without
question despite the fact that scars
sounds like the most obviously evil guy
of
all time why quiver with
fear now scar don't look at me that way
anyway fast forward
through some coming-of-age business
eating bugs blah blah blah never really
liked the timon and pumba section to be
honest forget akuna matata nine-year-old
matpat was
all about the political intrigue anyway
about 48 minutes into the movie we get
our first cut back to the pride lands so
we can see how poorly things are going
under scar's rule i feel like most
people probably remember this scene for
this bit
sing something with a little bumps in it
it's a small world
after all oh no anything
but that because disney doing
self-parody at the time was new
as opposed to something they do
literally every movie now but what these
tick-tackers call out in their short
little mini theory is scar picking his
teeth with some bones and playing around
with a large skull that as they imply
via google image search looks very much
like a lion skull
add to that the fact that hyenas
apparently don't tend to eat lions but
other lions do
and you've suddenly got yourself the
connection that suggests something much
more sinister
they think that the skull is actually
that of mufasa himself and that it's
evidence that scar not only killed his
brother
but cannibalized the evidence and kept
his bones as a trophy
now that's nasty but is it true well we
asked the world's top
experts online behavior but those people
are really expensive so instead we
looked it up on the internet
which is free and probably just as good
so let's start by looking beyond just
the headlines presented to us in this
tick tock forgive me if i'm a wee bit
skeptical of the evidence here being a
one-line
summary from the google result of a
mental floss article
the theory here really hinges on three
main details one that hyenas don't eat
lions
two that lions eat lions and three
that this is indeed a lion skull so
first do hyenas eat lions well despite
the fact that classy king's text
says that hyenas don't usually eat lions
the article he's showing in the
background
doesn't say that at all in fact that
whole article says
nothing about whether or not a hyena
will eat a lion
instead what he's highlighted in his
tick tock is talking about hyenas eating
lion
leftovers i.e whether hyenas follow
lions around to eat the remnants of
their meals which
fun fact they do but it's not as common
as media would lead you to believe yes
hyenas are scavengers but they also get
the vast majority of their food by
hunting for themselves and that is why
you don't believe disney movies or tick
tockers but okay still doesn't address
the question would hyenas eat a dead
lion and the answer to that is yes yes
they absolutely would to them
meat is meat is meat based on all of my
research spotted hyenas which is the
species that we see in the lion king
they're not picky eaters they're willing
and eager to eat everything from zebras
to birds to reptiles to bugs heck
they're even capable of eating rotten
meat without getting sick hyenas are
pretty much
garbage disposals with legs as such a
fresh lion carcass would be the
equivalent of a steak dinner for them
so already it's highly likely that if
presented with opportunity the hyenas
would absolutely have eaten mufasa
but here's the twist if they had you
wouldn't know it you see hyenas practice
osteophagy they eat bones animals do
this to supplement their diet with
calcium and phosphorus that their bodies
might be lacking and for hyenas they
leave no part of their meal wasted with
strong biting jaws and highly acidic
stomachs that are able to break down
bone efficiently
a pack of hyenas can entirely devour a
400 pound zebra 180 kilograms
in less than 25 minutes leaving behind
nothing well nothing but red stains on
the ground so while yes
they would have eaten mufasa gladly the
fact that his bones might still be
around imply that maybe they didn't
which brings us to question number two
would a lion eat another lion in the
tick tock we see classy kings google
search for what
animals eat lions what's hidden behind
those search result drop downs though
are the actual results and i'm here to
show em to ya
the top search result comes from what
eats.com where we see the following
quote
right there in the evidence box quote
lions have almost
no predators however old sick lions are
sometimes attacked
killed and eaten by hyenas which flies
directly in the face of the earlier
observation in the tick tock about
hyenas
man and people try to accuse me of
skewing the facts in order to fit my
theories
tick-tock you shameless anyway while the
evidence of a mufasa hyena feast keeps
stacking up digging deeper into the
facts you see that no
lions in fact do not tend to eat other
lions except in the most extreme of
circumstances
in fact this question was asked of derek
and beverly zhu bear wildlife
documentarian
studying lions on the podcast fresh air
but
if a lion kills a lion will the lion eat
no
the lion will not eat um another lion
and in fact
often the lions won't even eat other
predators so if they kill a hyena they
won't eat it either
unless they are in absolute uh desperate
times you know maybe at
death's door uh lions really don't um
have to
eat other predators but i mean if
they're dead already they still won't
eat them
no they don't and you know you can trust
them they have british accents the
reason why is that it just
doesn't yield a reward versus effort
food ratio that makes it worth hunting
one another
lions are violent creatures that are
hard to kill why put yourself at risk
trying to eat one when you can just try
and chase down another helpless zebra as
far as i can tell cannibalism in lions
is very
very rare only happening in cases of
desperate hunger and
almost never with an adult male
consuming another adult male
more often it's sometimes with lions
killing and eating the cubs of a rival
which again
doesn't really help us in the case of
mufasa's missing body the most famous
case of lion cannibalism actually came
with the mapago brothers a group of
six male lions who over the course of 16
years just roamed around a massive south
african national park declaring their
dominance by killing off
entire prides they were like the biker
gang of apex predators if this was the
walking dead they'd be like the savior's
gang
the six members of the mapago brothers
even had names there was the leader
makulu
rasta pretty boy kinky tail mr t
who pitied the fool and wouldn't you
know it but none other than scar but
despite our theory today it was mr t
who was the cannibal of the bunch eating
young cubs from rival prides but again a
super rare instance and not an adult
male eating another adult male also just
to throw this in here as a side note a
later scene in the tik tok theory shows
the quote that kinky tale one of the
mapago six was eventually killed and
eaten by a rival tribe of lions i looked
into that blog post
the writer and the death of kinky tale
which is part of a larger documentary on
that exact lion pack and there is
actually no evidence of the lion being
eaten even the author of the blog walks
back his language in a comment on the
post itself so i'd take that one with a
hefty grain of salt but who knows maybe
scar the movie lion and not the south
african lion bully just
really is that vindictive that he wants
to dunk on his dead royal brother by
dunking his brother's body in stomach
acid
which leaves us with our third and final
question is that even
a lion's skull in the scene no zero for
three on this one tic toc theory you see
lion classification is pretty simple in
the fact that there's only one species
of lion out there the panthera leo and
from there they've historically only
been two subspecies
african lions and asian lions which was
recently reorganized a bit but still
fairly simple breakdown and because of
that
the skulls of lions all tend to look the
same relatively short muzzle
large nasal cavities big orbital holes
for the eyes i'll admit the skull in the
movie does at first glance looks similar
to the google image results for
lion's skull but we're also talking
about a second or two of footage from a
tick tock
anything could look similar in that
amount of time look closer and you see
that the muzzle of the skull in the
movie is a lot longer than mufasa's
muzzle but
that's splitting hairs or splitting lion
noses i guess the real kicker here is
the teeth
lions have three types of teeth incisors
small teeth at the front of the mouth
for ripping and tearing big
canine teeth those long sharp teeth that
are used as weapons to capture and kill
prey and a third type of tooth called
the carnassial
large modified molar teeth found in the
back of the mouth which work like
scissors to cut the large chunks of meat
into smaller bits
it's actually a lesson that i taught
oliver the other day carnivores tend to
have sharp teeth because they need to
rip and tear meat
herbivores have flat teeth for grinding
plants and what do we see in the skull
that scar is holding
sure there's one big canine in there but
everything else is a lot of
small flat teeth with two oversized
incisors at the front of the mouth
notice that there's no secondary fangs
no prominent bottom jaw and most notably
of all
none of those weirdly shaped carnassial
teeth in the back for chopping meat now
compare that skull with the skull of a
primate
like say a baboon notice the oversized
front incisors the smaller flat molars
towards the back of the mouth the
overall longer muzzle that gives the
entire skull a more elongated shape i
don't know about you
but that seems like a much closer match
to what we're seeing
biologically in short our tick tock
theory stood upon three major points and
not a single one of them panned out not
one hyenas will eat dead lions
lions will attack and chew but tend not
to eat other adult lions even when in
territorial disputes and the skull we're
seeing
probably isn't even a lion's skull any
way you slice it this theory
is done plus even if we ignore all of
that and assume scar did try to eat
mufasa
he wouldn't have been able to do it all
at once even the largest male lions will
typically only eat about 16 pounds 7.25
kilos of food in a day
in reality lion packs will sometimes
stay close to a kill for a decent amount
of time to fend off scavengers until
they've completely finished it
in other words scar couldn't have sat
down and gobbled up his big bro on the
dl before jetting off to pride rock to
make himself the new king he'd have to
have done it over the course of
several days but our last bit of
evidence against this theory comes not
from science but from the story
here's the thing the reason we can even
do something like this for a 20 plus
year old disney cartoon about talking
lions and not for a lot of other talking
animal movies what do you want
i want you to go out and kill kill kill
uh earbud was a lot darker than i
remember is that lion king
actually has a philosophical core to
what happens in the movie
everything you see exists together in a
delicate balance
when we die our bodies become the grass
and the antelope eat
the grass and so we are all connected in
the great
circle of life that is barely 20 seconds
of dialogue from the great james earl
jones and it is some heavy stuff for a
kids movie but mufasa isn't just hanging
a lampshade on the whole yeah we totally
ate like half those guys in the front
row from that christening after the
elton john song but he's also setting up
the transcendental naturalism of this
movie's story
the philosophy that we have to accept
death as a part of life because it's a
part of the overall natural life cycle
he's describing nature as a cyclical
food chain positioning the proper death
for apex predators like himself and
simba as becoming the grass which just
so we're on the same page here
actually means that they become
fertilizer for the grass after their
bodies are eaten by vultures
insects worms and well anything else
that wants a crack at him or you know
his dead carcass just rots away in the
hot sun of the african serengeti think
about that for your childhood hero in
other words mufasa's view of how the
circle of life is supposed to work
wouldn't just be that his dying is
natural but that his
being eaten after dying is natural too
maybe not by his jerk brother ideally
but by something however the whole
second and third act plot of the lion
king hinges strongly on the implication
that his murder is such a fundamental
violation to the proper order of the
pride lands that it actually puts nature
and the world itself
out of balance symbolically that balance
begins to be restored
not when simba defeats scar but when
scar himself
gets eaten go back and watch the ending
again rain the number one thing you need
not only to put out the dramatic final
battle fire but also to restore life
after a drought
doesn't technically return when simba
wins it only comes after scar
himself gets eaten by the hyenas oh wait
there's a lion getting eaten by a hyena
forgot to put that moment in your
tik-tok theory huh now again this is
magical realism in action so it's not
exactly
proof of anything but if we were to
extrapolate a specific mechanic to all
of this we could infer that not only did
scar
not eat mufasa but maybe nobody did that
being murdered far away from where his
body could be a part of that symbolic
natural
cycle of life literally broke the chain
in the circle of life itself
and it isn't fully restored until scar
takes his place
literally and figuratively in the
stomachs of his own hyena foot soldiers
or maybe we're just overthinking it the
point is this any which way to sunday
we're gonna call this theory debunked
there's just no real proof here in the
movie's text the weird meta text or the
actual signs to support the idea that
scar
ate mufasa and all we had to do to prove
it was one remind you to double check
everything you see on tick tock and two
that everyone else in this beloved
family classic movie is eventually going
to gruesomely devour each other in one
way or another happy ending
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cuts
you